of interior affairs has confirmed that  they believe  this has been an organized terrorist  attack  so it started almost two hours ago  in the very center of vienna  and it was very near to to the the  synagogue in the seitan schreiten garcia  and this has uh brought memories to what  happened  40 years ago in 1980 there has been  already  an attack to the the synagogue  and and that's why uh the the police and  all the forces were highly alerted from  the first moment on  uh what we know until now is there are  several  attackers and in several places in  vienna  and uh police has said that the  policeman was shot  uh and as well as one of the attackers  there have been rumors that he blew  himself up with an explosive but this  has not been confirmed until now  and i had gotten information half an  hour ago that there was a second  incident near the hilton hotel which is  also  not so far from the place  from the pictures you have showed to  your audience  from the schwedenplatz